your friend that was uh warning you
about uh
marriage was he muslim
no i don't know what his religion is but
he wasn't muslim right because people
without faith
that that that is their religion so he's
giving you advice based on the religion
he lives by which is modernism
right secularism and so he's giving you
good advice
but not for a traditional muslim not not
for me and my woman and the way we live
our life
right we have a totally different set of
standards nobody wants any boundaries
they don't believe that there's a right
and a wrong they don't believe that
there is an objective
right and wrong some stuff is just wrong
but you but again once again you say
that like you said you get canceled you
can't tell that person is wrong
he's a pedosexual he was born that way
he likes to have sex with children
and this is they're pushing this that
there's a movement towards making that
okay
we take what's evil and make it good and
then it's crazy because you take what's
good
and you make it evil i live i
practically live
under a rock i see anybody on a
day-to-day basis
i have four children and my wife the
culture promotes a particular type of
man right the culture promotes the soft
man the effeminate man the weak man
um either that or it shows a completely
disordered
hyper aggressive man you know and so
there's no
there's really no in between and so
seeing
seeing these caricatures of men
you know on this on the screen or even
like i said in my
in my friends homes because my dad's not
from here's a key thing
distinction my dad's not from america so
a lot of the
my friends uh fathers were acting like
you know
bill cosby and homer simpson they were
they were acting the way they were
trained to act
by watching the media that they watched
and being in the culture my dad grew up
in a jungle my dad knew nothing about
any of this stuff he
he lived by the law of the jungle was
like if you it was you had to be an
alpha male just to survive it was like
you wouldn't you're not going to survive
out there if you don't
if you if you are actually masculine
you'll you'll suffer
[Music]
i definitely try to switch it up all the
time um
but definitely at least 15 to 30 minutes
every day i really like the one where i
just sit down
and i let whatever is going on in my
head go on
just so i can process everything and i
can kind of just see
what's happening behind the scenes like
there was one time when i was meditating
welcome back to another episode of the
three muslims podcast we are the realest
podcast in the dunya and today we have a
very very special guest masha allah
elliot hulse how are you doing today i'm
great thank you for having me
our pleasure it's our honor really uh
i know they want to talk a bit about uh
the inspiration that mr uh mr hulse is
to a lot of young men today let him talk
about that
he knows the best talk about how he's an
inspiration
yeah why don't you hype yourself up
no i won't do that because i did that
enough and the pride got to me
and it was my doubt i don't take any of
it seriously at
all you say our inspiration i don't know
i just talk to a camera
i upload bits to a screen and people do
it
whatever they want i'm
hands off i keep doing it because i make
money
if anything i'm just what they call you
a grifter i'm just a grifter
i'm just putting stuff out there because
youtube gives me money that's it i'm
trying to save the world not trying to
fear that trying to save everybody
i'm just doing what god called me to do
and i let i let the rest go
so okay question i know when you first
started
um you said you had an ego i'll say the
same thing for myself when i first
started youtube
um but what happened with you where you
kind of started realizing like ah okay
um this ego is kind of fake like
people showing me validation showing me
hey like this is kind of fake
when i started to believe it when i
started to uh
when i started to crave it i started
recognizing that
i put this video up and then i'm over
there i'm like waiting and looking like
all right
people are giving it thumbs up and there
was a time when i was the golden child
of youtube i would get i would have
video like 40 000 views and
zero dislikes i was like wow this is
amazing i must be amazing
everybody loves me i give good advice
and i'm saving everybody so i really
started and you know when people put
comments up that say that
you saved my life elliot you don't know
what you did for me ellie thank you so
much elliot
people will even say elliot is a god
and i read that and i'm like hmm
may maybe they're on to something
and as you know pride is before the fall
so and
and the same way that
i was able to i started taking in that
praise
was the same way that when the
when the negative started coming i
started i would take that in too
and i started realizing like wait a
second this is none of this all of this
is disordered it doesn't make any sense
the ups and the downs that i have to be
completely detached
otherwise i'm gonna i'm gonna be like uh
you know
a ship in a storm just up and down i
can't one of my teachers said this to me
when you know i was
many years ago when i was explaining to
him what was going on he says man you
subject yourself to the mass psychosis
you can't allow yourself to mirror the
the
the mental sickness of the people in the
world and that's basically what i was
doing
that's crazy dude and i guarantee when
people tell you yo
like heather you changed my life i see
you like a father figure like an uncle
like a brother or something like that
you're like oh that's awesome like
i'm glad i get help but it's like it
doesn't it doesn't go any further than
that
at least that's how it feels for me i
can't i ca because there was a time
when i at first i was inoculated against
it because i really didn't even
understand what was going on i was just
like whatever i'm just putting videos
and
and then i started to believe it and
then when i started to believe it then i
got lost
and so you know at this point wisdom has
taught me
that it's not even me it's whatever
they're receiving
you know it's not even really me on that
screen these are it's just bits on the
screen you know what i'm saying
uh they don't know me i don't know them
and so they can form their opinion
that maybe maybe i'm a great guy maybe
i'm not you know some people actually
found out that i'm not
i'm not as great as you thought i was
and that's
that's heartbreaking sometimes you got a
hero and you're like wait a second this
guy's a little screwed up
so yeah i'm a little screwed up and so
uh
don't put you don't hang your hopes on
me jeez man
we're all screwed up to be honest right
right exactly
yeah total around me bro go ahead man
well would you say that when you were in
that state um
you're maybe not your viewer of yourself
but how you felt depended on
uh people's perception of you so like
let's say one video you posted got a
million views and like
the first time next day you post and it
doesn't
that affect you you know how like
uh an alcoholic he gets that he has that
first drink and he doesn't know he's
about to become an alcoholic he has no
idea
but he gets that first drink he's like
man this this drink is great
i had such a great time and then he does
it again
and it's like okay it repeated it but
then he gets to a point where if he
don't if he doesn't get that high
then he wants another drink it's like
wait a second one drink used to do it
but now i need two drinks
now i need three drinks it's like i'm
not getting that high that i wanted
and so it's the same you know it works
that way with all kind of dopamine hits
that we get
and you know same thing with the screens
right uh
and i found it like okay so if i got a
high wow i gotta hide from this video
wow everybody loves that everybody loves
me i must be doing amazing
and then like you said another one comes
and it's like
oh i didn't get i didn't get the same
high on this one
let me go back let me go back and do it
again let me be a little bit more
eccentric
let me say a little bit more let me say
it louder let me be a little bit more
crazy
maybe they'll like this one and then
next thing you know
you know you lose your mind
[Laughter]
it's crazy that you say that too because
referring what you said before
was like you just putting something up
and like they're gonna take it how they
take it and it's like bro you might say
one thing
and your message might be one thing and
they're taking something completely
different
right yeah people hear what they want to
hear
that's another thing that you have to
keep in mind too people just hear what
they want to hear
so it's not even what i'm saying it's
crazy man
very unfortunate nowadays um especially
with like political correctness right
because they hear one thing where they
think they hear one thing and all of a
sudden it's like
something like alarms are ringing in
people's heads uh triggered
yeah that's the word that is the word
you gotta get triggered well i actually
i kind of enjoy
triggering people too because you don't
trigger people you don't
like you don't know the land mine is
there until you step on it
so triggering people kind of like i
think 2020
in a way kind of it sorted out the
it sorted things out because it's like
okay now i know who's who whoever it was
triggered and whoever was like
the the the crisis kind of brought
people's true colors
to the surface and that's kind of what
happens when you watch somebody get
triggered you're like oh
okay i see that you got that little
wound right there that's a
that's a little weak spot and if i just
touch that
you expose you expose your uh your
vulnerability
and so a lot of times i'll just do stuff
and i'll say stuff just because like i
want to see where people are at
and uh of course it's not always well
received
but that's the point it's like okay let
me see let me see who's
who's gonna have a hard time with this
are you referring
just to online or your phone also the
like in real life like the people you
communicate on a day-to-day basis
i live i practically live under a rock
i see anybody on a day-to-day basis i
have four children
and my wife and uh you know of course
i'll see
like tomorrow's my birthday and i'm
gonna take my father we're gonna go to
the florida gun show
and so i'll see my father i'll see my
brothers and siblings but
uh i don't really see anybody and i
can't i kind of prefer it this way
i don't want to i don't want to deal
with people really do you think that has
changed
or do you think it's always been like
that no i've always been
oh now i don't say always because i used
to
you know the world makes you believe
that extroversion is some sort of
uh it's better it's better to be out
there it's better to be in front of
people it's better to be
uh charismatic it's better to be in the
thick of stuff
and so i think a lot of people who would
generally be more
introverted or basically you know more
reserved and pulled into themselves
we uh because of the pressure or because
it's so delightful to the world we put
ourselves out there as extroverts and i
found that you know
maybe just because i'm getting old and
grumpy but over time i realized that
like
i don't really actually you like i don't
really want to be out there i don't want
to be out there i want to be dealing
everybody
i like i was very serious when i said
that you know i make videos because it's
my business it's my work
if i if it wasn't if there was no profit
in it
i wouldn't do this what am i gonna do
this for i would just
i would i could spend my days just
raising my kids we homeschooling now i'm
about to buy
we're moving to a ranch i could do
homesteading we can
raise chickens and goats and milk cows
and like there's so much other things to
do
you know what i'm saying so uh i'm not
that
i'm not that holy i'm not that much of a
nice guy like i'm just
giving myself a weight a lot of these
people a lot of these gurus like to
pretend like
i'm so altruistic that i'm
putting myself out there to change the
world
and uh if you're honest you're not
trying you're not putting yourself out
there changing the way you're putting
yourself out there because
you receive feedback because it is
there's uh
you know there's a sense of mirroring
that you get from people
uh if you're like yourself and me and
making youtube videos and people like
them
there's revenue that comes in uh
so i don't think anybody out there you
know not to say there aren't any people
but i say far
far few between are actually uh you know
doing it out of the out of their
overflowing of their heart
i just want to help people that's an ego
trip too
that's an ego trip yeah a show
it reminds me of uh when i first started
youtube
i was um i tried being real spiritual
and i had this like
spiritual ego and people were like oh
this man is so selfless he has no ego
but like
okay i had the biggest ego being the
spiritual guru
type deal and then i remember me and my
uh fiancee had split
and like at that point i was like man
forget this
and then like my real ego came out like
my real side and then people were like
oh man like he changed
this guy's a a piece of trash i'm like
no this is just me
right right right right exactly yeah
that's the same that's it right there
man and when they see your true colors
if
you didn't match up to the to the uh
idol that they make you in their head
then
you you fall out of grace like i did
but that's okay it's like that box you
said people put you in that box
right damn yeah i still remember that i
don't want to be in that box
i was going to say what are what are
some important values that you can see
behind humility today
because narcissism is at an all-time
high oh yeah
as long as you have a screen in front of
your face as long as you got a
one of these you can't help but be
narcissist
because it it's a mirror of you
especially if you're on social media
this thing is a mirror
you know the story of how the word
narcissist came about you know the story
of
narcissus right i think it's a i think
it's an old greek story or something
but narcissus was he was he was marching
with the warriors right i guess they
were going off the battle or something
right
and as they're marching and they took a
stop they went to a pond
and when they stopped to get some water
at the pond
he looked in the pawn he saw his his
reflection and he
marveled at his reflection right he
marveled at his reflection he couldn't
take his eyes off
he was like wow and the curse that was
set upon him
because he because all the soldiers left
right and he was just
he was just so taken in by his the image
of himself
that uh for the rest of his life check
this out this is funny
for the rest of his life the curse was
that
he would these birds would follow him
around
and repeat everything that he says every
word he says would be repeated back to
him
what is this this is the birds repeating
back everything that we we
saying to ourselves all right every time
i open this up and i say youtube i see
myself
in fact i caught my son watching my
youtube videos today and i'm and it's
like
i can't get my the voice my own voice i
can't get it out of my head
it's just following me around so uh i
like that you say that you know
that narcissism is ever present but it's
so insidious
and it's uh
particularly with the with the screens
you know i didn't grow up with this this
is brand new this is brand new to me
essentially
um when i grow up there was a phone on
the wall we had it tethered to the wall
with a wire
uh these are totally different uh
by mere virtue of these these screens
existing
you can't have one and not be a
narcissist have you ever taken a selfie
have you ever taken a selfie of your
narcissist
you're looking at yourself
yeah 100 i agree man and what do you
think that humility has
in the in our role in the universe as a
creation
as opposed to the creator well by by
mere virtue of you even
saying that is an act of humility
recognizing that i am not god i am not
the creator
we've been in our society they we become
our own gods
do what you want right your truth
uh if it feels good right so essentially
we
we become the subjective standard by
which we live our lives rather than an
objective standard
by by fact of i'm not the creator
god the father is the creator and so
as uh as far as humility is concerned
it's knowing
your place that's really what it is
knowing your right place in the order of
things
not being inflated or uh deluded
about your position in things my i'm
i'm beneath i'm beneath i'm not above
and by holding that just even like you
said just holding that
thought that i'm a creation i'm i'm a
i'm a creature right even to say that
right isn't that
does isn't that like uh if you say
something like that it hurts people
feeling right like uh
you know you you can't say stuff like
that you're a creature are you
denigrating me
the sjw coming get you uh but to
recognize that yeah i'm dust man i'm
dust from dust to dust
i am nothing i'm here like this i'm
gonna be gone and to live your life with
that remembrance
will provide some level of humility at
least
it's nice it reminds me the story you
were telling about narcissist
doesn't he die at the end doesn't he
fall into
the the pond the lake and um
then at the end the lake was crying or
something like that and then
i think like the birds or something
asked the leg oh why are you crying
it's like oh well now i can't see my own
reflection and narcissists
wow and like it's the tangled web yeah i
don't know if that is the story
i might be butchering it but um if
if we were to include that and we we do
talk about this it's like
without the humility that's what's
happening to people
right you have this phone you get this
narcissism that starts to develop
and if you don't check yourself or you
have no one to check you like that's
that's a downward spiral yeah it can
consume us
i hope if you think about it it's kind
of like
this um this like top tier
perception of what we should be like is
dictated by you know the society we
you know we live in this this
liberalistic movement of you know
like you said you know do you you know
your truth so on and so forth
not only is it promoting narcissism but
it's saying you should also look like
this talk like this say these things
don't say those things this you know
this is
the gray area and this you just never
say or else right
wiped off the face of the earth all
right cancel
exactly and it actually reminds me of a
verse in the quran where it says have
you seen the one who has taken his own
desires as
is his own god right and if you think
about it that's so profound and that's
today whatever you feel you do it that's
why so many different things including
like pedophilia nowadays trying to be
integrated into
us and all that um because they were
born this way no they just
hire these things and that's right a
huge problem nowadays
right right nobody wants any boundaries
they don't believe that there's a right
and a wrong they don't believe that
there is an objective
right and wrong some stuff is just wrong
but you but again once again you say
that like you said you get canceled you
can't tell that person is wrong
he's a pedosexual he was born that way
he likes to have sex with children
and this is they're pushing this that
there's a movement towards making that
okay
we take what's evil and make it good and
then it's crazy because you take what's
good
and you make it evil that's what they do
100
100 um we actually talked about this
pretty often like the the concept of
marriage right
it's it's very big just like it's making
christianity it's big in islam right
um but it's it's supposed to be made so
easy but nowadays it's so
difficult and like i'm 20 when i tell
people oh yeah i'm trying
like i'm getting married soon they like
lose their fun guy at work he's like
like it's like he didn't even want to
talk he was warning me actually like be
careful you know
it's crazy but it's so true like um we
have a concept of halal permissible and
prohibited awful and insinful
and we have a saying that people make
the lawful
sinful and they make the sinful lawful
and it's right it's very sad and it's
all
backed by secularism which is removing
um
religion right i was thinking about this
recently i just like to end off this
note
i'll think about it recently it's it's
so egotistical it's so narcissistic to
be human beings
and understand that there's a
possibility god exists and a possibility
god's law
exists but to think even if it's a
possibility i don't care if it's true
i'm going to make my own laws i'm going
to make my own rules i'm going to govern
myself
um that's the biggest most narcissistic
mindset i think anyone can have nowadays
yeah problematic yeah i agree with you
and that's exactly where they are
where they are um your friend that was
uh warning you about uh marriage was he
muslim
no i don't know what his religion is but
he wasn't muslim right because people
without faith
that that that is their religion so he's
giving you advice based on the religion
he lives by which is modernism
right secularism and so he's giving you
good advice
but not for a traditional muslim not for
me and my woman in the way we live our
life
right we have a totally different set of
standards
amazing that you put it that way because
it's always uh it's always a matter of
perception
right um everyone on their side is the
hero and the other side's always the
enemy
at the end of the day so the way he's
looking at it is like 20 because he has
marriage as one thing i have marriages
like to him marriage is like after
you've been with x amount of people
you're ready to settle down
for me it's like i'm ready to embark on
this journey in my life to uh to be with
someone to
you know fulfill god's will so on and so
forth right
but um i feel like a lot of the problems
we have nowadays
is backed by something you talk a lot
something that we're all passionate
about which is um
you know masculinity manhood and having
good father figures because they
ought to be the ones to teach their sons
masculinity manhood
and how to be a proper father um so
let's start off with the positives what
do you think the positives
are in having a good father figure or
having society of good father figures
well we do know statistically that uh
single mother homes or where there's
absence of fathers
there's an increase in everything from
obesity to disease
to incarceration to depression to drug
abuse to
all all the bad stuff if you look at the
statistics
generally come from the rot of the
family from the breakdown of the family
from
feminism essentially because that's what
brought in this divide
to uh to fracture the family
so uh you know the very first thing we
have to consider is that a society
cannot
hold itself together cannot be a
virtuous society cannot be a good
society
if there are not strong families and
we cannot have strong families if we do
not have strong fathers and we
we're suffering the repercussions of
this right now
in every instance that there was a uh
a mass shooting you know in america you
got all these
mass shootings the media pumps this
stuff up um
every instance one thing has in common
is that
the the boys were fatherless and they
were raised in daycare
so it's not only the fatherlessness but
when there's fatherlessness there's
motherlessness
because then the state becomes the daddy
then care for the children and for the
family rearing of the family
gets outsourced to strangers essentially
and so uh we got to make a comeback you
got to make a comeback
to good families
and the way good families are gonna make
come back is by having strong men women
can't do it
it's not their responsibilities not
their place to do it it's up to us
just completely unfair to expect the mom
to be the mom and the dad
uh and to expect a child to look at a
woman and and
take fatherly advice from her it doesn't
make sense
i just want to just take advice but the
mirroring right like
men know how to be men only when we're
in the presence of men we can't because
there's mirror neurons we have to be
able to see it right
if i've never seen never been in the
presence of
never interacted with a strong alpha
male leader
i'm not even going to know how to first
of all i will never know that in myself
but if i see one i'm not going to even
know how what to do with that guy
i have this one kid in my king
transformation program last night we
were talking it was pretty cool he grew
up in his home
uh with just his mother and his sisters
and he you know he's clever he
he figures some stuff out he knows like
you know something's not right here
well uh this week he went to tennessee
to go
stay with his uncle for a little bit and
his uncle is like alpha male his uncle's
a good man he's
and his wife he's a submissive wife he's
got a good wife and so he called me from
there yesterday and i was talking to him
he's like
i've never seen this before like the way
my uncle carries himself
and the respect that his wife has for
him and the way the children speak to
him
i was like this is a this is like
mind-blowing to me
and he was trying to explain to me like
that now i get it now i kind of
understand
some of the things you're talking about
because i can see it but if you've never
seen that and you're not going to see it
on the tv
you're not going to hear about it on the
music the media is totally
degenerate so the minute they see
and what typically happens is the minute
they do if they're not if they're right
if they if they're not open
if they're not if they don't recognize
there's a problem
a lot of times they'll reject you know
that man that's why they call it toxic
they'll reject any kind of a strong
alpha male masculine man immediately
it's like oh
get him away from me that's a bad man
he'll fly do you guys have anything to
doubt this i know you guys yeah i was
gonna say
that um just to add on to what you said
elliot
was like we need to have that strong man
and if you don't have
if a kid is fatherless then he's also
motherless
and like man i think that rings true
because
speaking from myself i love my mom
i love my mom just like i'm sure most of
the people will say they love their mom
as well
but you know what like my mom tried to
be there
but you know she was going through her
own thing because her and her husband
got divorced my dad at the time
and then her just kind of going through
that but then trying to be there for us
and then also trying to
talk to other men trying to get out into
the playing field again and then
bringing
a guy who doesn't give two shits
about me or my sister right like that
that's where like things start getting
uh the lines start getting blurred and
that's what happens to a lot of people
as well where it's like
if they happen to have a dude come into
their life like a stepfather
like nine times out of ten that
stepfather is pretty abusive pretty uh
pretty toxic you know what i mean
[Music]
i could imagine because it's not your
kids you shouldn't be boning that woman
anyway right
i don't i don't think it's and this is
just my opinion i'm not
calling anybody out but
i don't see why any man will get
involved with a woman that has children
she should be with her husband they
should figure it out that's just my
opinion they should figure it out
and if they can't and she needs to be
and this is the same thing for men too i
don't think
i don't think it's right for men to be
hopping from wife to wife
uh then you stay alone if you can't
figure it out with one woman then you
know what it means it means you need to
figure it out you need to figure this
out on yourself
you need to be by yourself and you and
you even because of the failure in your
family in that way
you need to allow yourself to pay the
penance pay the price
mortify yourself a little bit by not
getting back into the pleasure of having
you know another partner right because a
lot of times that quote-unquote partner
is just somebody that they're going to
project their
neediness on and you know get their
rocks off on and
uh if that person has a family or if you
have a family yourself
you you're not doing you you're not
doing any service to the children you're
just making it worse
okay cool i wanted to i wanted to kind
of rewind
a little bit i know before this this
current call that we're on
we talked a little bit about your
childhood and how a lot of the traits
that you
have observed in your father at the time
you couldn't really see the
wisdom and value that you do now so what
are some of those things that you
you've seen and witnessed growing up
that you didn't really vibe with and
resonate with but you do see now
well
a lot of it had comes from the fact that
the
culture promotes a particular type of
man right the culture promotes the soft
man the effeminate man the weak man
um either that or it shows a completely
disordered
hyper aggressive man you know and so
there's no there's really no in between
and so seeing seeing these caricatures
of men you know on this on the screen
or even like i said in my in my friends
homes because my dad's not from he
this here's a key thing distinction my
dad's not from america
so a lot of the my friends uh fathers
were acting like you know bill cosby and
homer simpson they were
they were acting the way they were
trained to act by watching the media
that they watched
and being in the culture my dad grew up
in the jungle my dad knew nothing about
any of this stuff he
he lived by the law of the jungle was
like if you it was you had to be an
alpha male just to survive it was like
you wouldn't you're not going to survive
out there if you don't
if you if you are actually masculine
you'll you'll suffer
uh and then he came to america so a lot
of the things that he would do and a lot
of things he would say
would would just be considered uh toxic
and taboo
and you would never see like a like a uh
like a bill cosby or something say it
or do it a couple of the things that my
dad like he
he hammers home and he he talks in terms
of
you know things that a lot of people
would reject
is his relationship to my mother and
like
my parents are funny because he says all
this stuff right in front of her and
he'll say things like you know you don't
need a useless woman
a woman who can't cook a woman who can't
clean a woman who can't take care of the
kids
he's a useless woman and i remember when
he used to say stuff like that because i
grew up in this feminist world
i'll be like that's not true dad that's
not true you got to love somebody for
their heart not for what they can do at
least you know
i would argue with him like that's not
true just you know you could get
somebody else to
to cook and clean and you know and it's
good for a woman to go out and you know
have a career
i believed all that stuff because as the
world told me but then as by and by and
as i watched
other families falling apart and having
the struggles that they have that my
my family didn't have i started to
realize oh
maybe that's why maybe that maybe my dad
was right
because he said all these things and now
i'm looking around and i'm realizing
that people that live by the law that i
thought was right their lives are
falling apart
yet my parents have been together for
like 50 years and
they they're great they're fine and they
raised us
to be the same way i've been with my
wife going on
we we started dating when we were in
high school right i know you get married
at 20 i got married at 23.
but i practically married that girl when
i was in high school
i haven't so it had that long-term
uh that long-term successful
relationship
is very rare and i attribute a lot to
the way my parents were
traditional gender roles that's a big
part for my dad traditional gender roles
so i know you said that your pop said uh
the whole thing about the useless woman
but what else did he say and do
that was just completely different from
him he used to spike
that's another big difference that's
another huge difference my dad used to
whoop us he had no
qualms about whoop take off that belt
and he'll hold your hand up and you get
a couple clappings on your butt him and
my aunt used to whoop us
you can't do that anymore you can't even
you can't even bring that up because
that's child abuse
so i you know my and my mom she was like
part of the culture a little bit more
into the culture as women typically are
you know she watched
oprah and [ __ ] like that and she started
getting worried she's like
edmond your children are gonna tell
they're gonna go to the psychologist
and they're gonna say that you abuse
them and that they're traumatized
so my mom would like you know kind of
stand up for her sometimes because she's
like
you're gonna traumatize the children
because look and she was watching like
oprah
and but he didn't pay her no mind i'm
happy he didn't
there were some other old school things
like we didn't
and this may sound seem insignificant
especially today when we have like the
screens
but like for example uh we had no cable
tv growing up
when everybody had cable teammates i
don't want you watching any of that we
had no cables we had six channels
and one tv right uh we had to be home
for dinner and we ate dinner with the
family every night
that's no none of my neighbors we i
would be upset
because i'm like i gotta come home i
gotta eat dinner and i look out the
window my friends are still running
around out in the street
and here i am is like come home because
my dad's home i gotta eat dinner
sundays right sundays we weren't allowed
to go out we weren't allowed to do
anything
uh my dad put up a lot of boundaries i
think that's what i'm getting at
at a certain point like i i began to
recognize that like why am
is dad so strict why do we have so many
rules why are so many boundaries
uh we couldn't go out past like uh eight
o'clock at night or something like that
i forget what it was
but it'll be like still bright outside
we got to come inside but
my friends are still out there running
around and we would just be shouting at
them through the window because my dad
is mean
and so of course i resented him i i i
rejected a lot of that when i was a kid
but then i started growing up and i
started to recognize the difference
between myself and
other children as they grew and now it's
so evident
now because i'm a father and i look at
all the broken families
all the broken families and the way
my generation is raising their kids or
lack thereof
i knew that i know now i'm like okay my
dad did something right and especially
when i started bumping into various
challenges with my own children
because again i grew up in this blue
pill baitified world i was a blue pill
beta 5 boy
and so you know then i had three
daughters that's
what red pill me a lot too was the fact
it's like wait a second okay i got three
daughters now
and so this my dad had three sons it was
three of us
so he i had to i had to be
based on a totally different level than
my father because the manipulation to
the young women in this world
is bad for men right with porn oh man
it's so bad for men
but it's real bad for girls it's just
real bad for girls too
they can't i got to a certain age with
my daughters
where i couldn't buy i couldn't find
modest clothing for them
i'm like why is this this is my
nine-year-old daughter why can't i find
a pair of shorts that doesn't it's not
like
all the way up her leg it does it not
exist
it don't exist you have to go and uh
like do like the amish you got to make
your own
a lot like i know muslims you guys have
you have the special
special guard put on that whole thing
cover yourself cover everything except
your eyes
and uh and i see the value in it i'm
like yeah that's right there should be
some modest clothing there should be
some
modest boundaries right i see these guys
they got daughters the same age as mine
i got rules for my daughters you
you can't show they can't show cleavage
you don't show your belly button
your shirt your skirt your shorts got to
be a certain length
i don't understand when i walk out there
and i see these men walking around with
their daughters and their daughters look
their daughter's like all tied up into
the belly button
showing and the tits out i'm like this
is your this is your 15 year old
daughter and you just walking with her
like that's okay
i i have a problem with that and this is
all comes from you know
this might because my dad was like that
had one sister he was like that with my
sister
so uh all this to say
that i'm happy that i saw i grew up in a
home with a strong father
that set those boundaries so when it
came time for me to set boundaries
i had something to mirror and that's
when my dad started becoming my best
friend
and i started asking him like okay what
am i going to do here dad in this
situation he was like
remember what i did with you i'm like ah
okay that's why
i get it so what did you see different
in yourself growing up between like the
other kids
well i wasn't much different than other
kids personally
right meaning like you know i had the
same values i watched the same cartoons
i was playing the same video games
i went to the same school right so i had
the same brainwashing as them
the only difference was that i had a
stricter i had a stricter father at home
you would say that that it was something
that manifested itself
later in life i was able to see the
benefit
of being in that situation with my
father
when i started having children myself
that's when that's when
that's when it started making that's
when it started showing the difference
that's when the difference started
manifesting itself to me and i watched
the other people and i'm like wow
uh they're having a hard time because
they don't know how to especially men
they don't know how to
set up boundaries because nobody set up
boundaries for them if nobody set up
boundaries for you you don't know
anything about boundaries how are you
going to put up boundaries
you know nothing about it especially in
a world that calls boundaries oppressive
but you trying to put up a wall you
trying to
keep you're trying to keep certain
things in and certain things
out you're not supposed to do that
everybody's supposed to mix
and it's supposed to be we're all one
big orgy
but that's that's a recipe for chaos you
need boundaries
every garden my father's a gardener and
one of the things he
uses an analogy for me he's like you see
my garden here
notice every time because he just moved
to another house susan notice every time
i
set up a garden what does the first
thing i do i put boundaries
he puts a wall up or some sort of
boundaries boundaries of trees
it's like because you got to keep out
the things that you don't want
destroying
the the the flowers that's in here and
he's he treated our family the same
exact way
we were only we were the only house on
the block we were the only house on the
block that had a big
fence around it it was the strangest
thing
we had a lot big chain lick fence and
all the other neighbors just had wide
open
yards and stuff and i would ask my dad
you know what's going on
and i'll say my dad why do we have a
fence around the house and he says cause
you see that fence
everything on the inside of this fence
i'm responsible for
i take care of there are certain rules
certain boundaries way things that are
done
inside this fence i can't control what's
happening on the outside of that fence
and i don't know what's going to happen
when you go on the outside of the fence
but you know how things are
on the inside of this fence and just by
mere virtue of having that
boundary let me know that there's
there's a difference there's a contrast
it's a right and wrong
there's polarity
it reminds me of a lion king
you remember lion king well you said
like oh you see you see this everywhere
where the sun touches like that's the
pride and like everywhere with the sun
like doesn't touch like we don't go over
there like
there's nothing over there hey there's
none of our business that's their
business okay that's okay
a lot of people might be tuning in now
and wondering that whatever um you were
talking about eliot about this whole
thing about promiscuity
and how you know it's not in our best
interest to just
you know get it in with everyone that
comes across us
they might even be wondering why like
isn't that normal to have experiences to
get to know more people and then see
what you really like what are the values
of
of modesty and you know not being
promiscuous especially from
someone like yourself who's been with
the same woman since uh you were 14.
the first thing that we have to take
into consideration as men
is our addictive personalities men get
very quickly addicted to things
that's why pornography is so proliferant
this is why video games are so preferent
we get it we get a high from something
and it's not to say that women don't too
but there's something within the male
genome
that makes us once we get what we want
we want more of it want more of it i
want more of it
we become attached to it this is why you
know most men most alcoholics are men
most drug addicts are men
is men uh sex is no different because
when you have sex there's a
there's a explosion of neural chemicals
in your mind that are
very similar to that of somebody who
takes a heroin hit
it's a it's a drug sex in a lot of ways
is a drug
and what ends up happening when you're
addicted to a drug
the drug dealer becomes your god you
ever see a crack addict i haven't seen a
crack at it before if you watch like
movies and stuff i've seen them on tv
you ever if you see the crack head
talking to the crack attic and he's over
there looking like yeah man i need my
fix i don't have anything right now but
i need some
he's so he's he needs it so bad
you see the same you see the men acting
the same way with these women after they
start having sex with them
the minute i had a guy on my call last
night and he knows it about himself now
the
minute they put their penis in a woman
that's it all that's
off they become lost because they're
addicted to that woman's sex
and and the worst thing is that they
don't even know that woman
because once they start having sex with
that woman they put on the sex goggles
when you have one of those sex goggles
you don't see that woman anymore all you
see is that
oh you start getting that feeling
between your legs and it's like oh
man i just can't wait to get into that
once again it's
a it's an addiction it's a feminacy and
it makes men
lose themselves so i'm just talking in
terms of the the
the deleterious effects of promiscuity
for men
also in a world that that uh
that glorifies pleasure
a world that that doesn't see the value
in
mortification see the value in suffering
see the value
and discipline really see the value in
restraint
chastity right there's no the world
doesn't promote that the world promotes
have fun feel good do what you want do
what you like
uh we get lost in we get lost
in um
we get lost in effeminacy we get lost in
addiction we get lost in pleasure
and if you're lost in pleasure there's
no room for the father there's no room
for the father there's no room for god
when you're
when you're pleasure seeking when you're
when you're addicted to a drug and
that's nine times out of ten that's what
the issue is
with the in my mind as far as it relates
to
something that most young men can relate
to because there's a whole lot of
reasons why it's it's not a good idea
but the number one is that it destroys
men's lives because they lose
themselves in islam we have uh this
whole concept of
nekker which is a marriage between two
people
and we're not allowed to be promiscuous
and we we need a negative and one of the
main reasons and the wisdom behind it
from god is that it assures
paternity there's this line of heredity
there's no
fatherlessness going around going around
which is at an all-time high today like
we mentioned
and uh everyone knows who is linked to
who because if you have kids with
someone then
you have to know who the father is
because they're unionized they're
married
right it's not like you could just you
know do it with like five people and
then you don't know who the father is
because you know that's also one of the
reasons um you know in in islam at least
um women have to be monogamous because
if women are not monogamous then you
can't tell who the
father is yeah and there's a whole lot
of father confusion out there
there's a whole industry uh based on
trying to get paternity tests to see who
daddy is it's a mess so i agree with
that too that's another
that's another great reason not to have
sex out of wedlock
[Music]
now take a step back because my mind is
still on this other thing
but um you had this programming from
your pops
right he basically structured a
foundational programming
that for the most part it kind of went
to the side as you went into this world
the
you started getting the programming of
this world of everything that you were
experiencing but then later in life
you started realizing like oh this ain't
quite right
this isn't working here and then that's
when you realize okay well i need to
change something then when you went back
you realize
oh i actually already have this
programming that my dad
instilled on me when i was a young kid
which that was a huge benefit for you so
question that i have for you
is someone who didn't have that how can
they
go about um restructuring and
reprogramming them
reprogramming themselves to where they
can start to be
that masculine male in their lives
you know uh i'm grateful that i have my
father
and i'm grateful that i i was able to
return to him right because that doesn't
always happen right you could have a
good father
that's why i say as tough as parents
because you could do all the right
things
and your children can still reject you
and that's it it's like what are you
gonna do the culture that's
you're screwed that's it um i'm grateful
for the fact
that i was able to return to my father
and there's a
there's a cross-cultural pattern
uh that's that's
according to anthropologist mercer
eliade
uh in terms of male initiation masculine
initiation it happens you know
when he did his study he recognized like
all primitive societies all traditional
societies
have this movement away from the world
of the mother and this atonement with
the world of the father that needs to
happen
and a boy does not become a man until
this process happens where
he is removed from the world of mother i
like to think of the word
mother in the same word same way as
matter
as uh material as matrix
matriarchy uh it's all about the
physical representation
of pleasure uh in life you know it's
it's what's comfort it's where we come
from right
it's emotion it's pleasure it's comfort
and the mother represents that
and it's fine it's good until a certain
point when the boy actually has to make
something
of himself is it become of some value to
society and he can't continue to be
wrapped up in the world of the mother
the world of the matrix the world of
material comfort
creature comfort and so the way this
would happen
is that they would generally
remove the boy from the mother and then
he would be uh he would have
challenges and austerities opposed upon
him
my brother did a native american uh
ritual of this sort
uh many years ago he was in college and
he took him up to the top of a cliff
and they put they sat him down on us on
a big rock
and drew a circle around him and they
said okay now you need to sit there for
four days and that's what you had to do
to sit there for four days
what that does is it breaks you of your
addiction it breaks you of your
addiction to pleasure
breaks you of your addiction to mommy to
comfort to
uh even this sense of um
there's a sense of there's a sense of
pride that's associated with getting
that pleasure
and getting whatever you want and being
a mama's boy all that needs to be broken
the entire ego needs to be broken down
and so this is where the right you would
call it a rise of passage
this is where the rights of passage
would come in and that's the middle
that's the middle transition
moving away from the world of the mother
rights of passage meaning you're being
challenged you
usually do fasting it's usually some
kind of challenge you know maybe they
would like
depending on the society maybe you gotta
kill a bear or something like that
um but it was always something tough to
break you down right a young man needs
that he's
a little bit of toughness in his life
and then the third and final
come around would be the atonement with
the world of the father and this is
where religion
comes in this is where mythology comes
in this is where meaning and purpose in
life
a transcendent purpose you know the
ancestors or god the father
something more transcendent something
bigger than ourselves becomes instilled
into the into the young man so that when
he comes back into society he has a
sense of dignity
right rather than just you know the way
most men young living their lives today
there's no purpose there's no meaning
there's no dignity and so
knowing that that's the pattern movement
away from pleasure
challenge and then meaning we could put
because the grandfathers don't do that
because the fathers don't do that
because the answers don't do that
anymore
we could find a way to do it for
ourselves i noticed i think i even
noticed in some of your videos you talk
about like dopamine detoxes and taking
cold
showers and you know doing things that
are tough so that you
see you're breaking yourself of that
effeminate attachment
break yourself away from screens for a
little while
fast maybe take some cold showers
do something tough do something
challenging put away
all the all the little baby boy
addictions right
um fasting is huge fasting is probably
the easiest way to just get right into
it because we
we're so food is so insidious we're
eating all the time
i know you guys fast for ramadan that's
a great idea that's an amazing idea
everybody i think everybody should fast
but once once you can break away
from our creature comforts our
addictions right
the pleasures in our life that's good
that's a good start
that's a very good start it's a good
start but you need some sense of meaning
in your life
because then you're gonna come back and
in the bible the same way jesus says
something to the effect of when you kick
out
he's talking about uh casting out demons
from somebody
he sees this analogy he says when you
kick
out the demons from this house he's
using an analogy as a house you kick the
teams out of his house
if you don't fill that house back up
with something right the demon's gonna
come back with seven of his friends he's
coming right back
just cause you kicked them out just
cause you cleaned up your act just
because you
did some fasting and you did some
austerity if you don't
now take that clean slate and print
something right on it it's gonna go
right you can go right back you can go
right back bro
and so i'm a fan of religion that's why
i'm a fan of religion i think i think
for a man to be a manly man he has to
have the boundaries
of a religion of a faith if he has so he
has some kind of meanings not a purpose
in his life
so religion and fasting and
did you say i think you said at one
point in one of the videos that
you started getting into a martial arts
did you start doing muay thai yeah i did
more time i did it for a while i did for
like maybe like six months i didn't
stick with it how'd you like it
i liked it i liked it just because of
the workout itself just
whooping that bag like i just i would be
in there and i'd be shouting
everybody knew when ellie was coming
because i was just i just want to beat
the crap out of that bag but for me it
was just like getting energy out
you know did you did they have a heavy
spa or anything like that
yeah we did some sparring
[Laughter]
i'm a rough guy i don't know how to go
halfway so every time we smart guys
would get mad would be like calm down
elliott
did anyone uh let anyone man handle you
now that's muay thai i did jiu jitsu for
about two weeks
and i was done i had i had i had this
uh like 20 year old girl wrap her
legs around my neck and almost took the
[ __ ] out of me and i was like okay i
don't know i can't do this
yeah jiu jitsu was tough those guys
they're like little spiders they just
get you know the next thing you know i'm
getting choked out
and i will use all my muscle i'll use
all my might trying to fight but like
they would just rest and they would wait
and at the next moment like a bowl
constrictor this rap
just choked me out so i was like i'm not
doing this anymore
all right so when when the chick pretty
much crushed your neck how did you feel
after that
emasculated actually right yeah
i mean i was kind of joking because you
know if i really if i wanted to
all i had to do is just i would broke
her ribs
but uh so of course you know i let her
beat me but she was technically she's a
lot better than me technically
um but i rec what i recognize is that
this is
a um as a as a as an art
as a skill it's something that will take
years and years to develop and i wasn't
interested in that's not what i was
there for
i was there to just you know learn a few
different ways that i could defend
myself and just get a good workout
and so that's fine that was better for
me yeah that's fair that's fair
yeah i live in florida so we have uh we
have open carry so i just if
i have a problem yeah yeah i live in
florida too bro so i know how it is
mr kerry yes sir yes sir i was on
on a side note i don't know if you know
this guy but um his name's peter perez
probably don't know him but um me and
him were boys at one point and
we used to watch your videos all the
time back in like 2015 not to hype you
up man but like we were trying to come
down to st
petersburg just so we could check out
your gym
so it's uh it's crazy because like we
literally only stay like a few hours
away
where do you live at the moment i stay
in claremont
oh i'm moving to lake county get out of
here
yeah i'm moving to lake county uh at the
end of this month eustis
that's crazy yeah we bought 40 acres
that's dude um that's a blessing
yeah that's the strength camp ranch
we're gonna hold my vents there you've
been you've been talking about that
that new uh that new place are you gonna
start farming and all that
yep it's coming so speaking of ramadan
uh
ironically you brought it up and it's
elliott it's four or five days away
and uh you made a wonderful video
that struck me about ramadan and
a brother came to you and asked the
question something along the lines of
ramadan might ruin my games right what
should i do
and uh you know maybe your advice back
then might be the same
you know because it's been a few years
people change so uh
what is your message to today um for
people that are wondering
will ramadan ruin these material things
these physical things you know
my routines physicality uh strengths
uh you know proteins what do you have to
say that's the point
that's the point that's the point to die
to yourself right that's what fasting
kind of is fasting is like a little
death to your ego
and so if you're trying to hold on to
stuff while you're going through this
modification process
you're missing the point the whole point
is to let go of all that
it's and it's only a short period of
time right what you want is going to
come back
could you could you dedicate these days
to god and just
put your ego aside for a little while
maybe you lose a few pounds what's the
big deal
you're gonna gain it back maybe you know
whatever it is that you're afraid is
gonna happen
offer that up offer that up to the lord
and say look
take this away from me i don't want to
be addicted to it i want to do this for
you i'm not doing it for me
and that's the attitude that you i
imagine that's the attitude that you
want to have when you go into it not
fearful about what you're going to lose
think about what you could gain even
right a new sense of clarity
new sense of devotion
that's really similar to what you were
saying before about um
having a good moral standing that's why
you love religion right
i remember hearing there's three things
everybody needs in life something to do
something to love and something to look
forward to and if you look at religion
it provides all three of those things in
and of itself
yeah the beautiful thing because when
you like having good
action is one thing right but if you
lack the faith
then the actions kind of void right
right
and if you have good morals but you're
not acting on it then
what's the point of that it's in your
head and you're gonna experience
cognitive dissonance and
all these troubles but when you have
good faith and good actions they come
together then you're really being
and at that point and it's it's it's a
beautiful thing things like fasting and
giving up these dopamine highs
wholeheartedly for the sake of god now
you're getting
you know the full picture and you're
really right
so even asking a question like that it's
almost self-defeating
um like how do i get rid of the stuff
but hold on to it right
right yeah exactly they contradict each
other
um
yeah i'm just like kind of i'm thinking
here for a second that lot
dude i'm that guy that always
backtracking the conversation my bad
but um throughout your entire life have
you ever been
manhandled and there's a point for me
asking this i just want to know i'm not
trying to like
you know make fun of you or anything
like that manhandle what do you mean by
that
like let's say you got into a fight and
you got yes
or you went to the martial arts and you
got your ass handed to you like
the chick crushing your throat
i don't know if i would ever say i got
manhandled but i definitely have been
humiliated
before um you know there have been times
i've gotten jumped before
right and you know the these these are
kids that like they jump me in and run
so i wasn't manhandled i was ambushed
i'm thinking of a couple of
situations like that um you know as far
as the jiu jitsu was concerned
that was that was a you know that's
practice right like i said
i wanted to crush that girl's ribs all i
got to do is suplex
that's it she'd be done um but i've
definitely been
i've been humiliated physically and
morally you know
several times i mean and then i compete
in sports so
like you know i did real well at strong
man it was the last sport that i really
competed in there were times those guys
would just they would just destroy me
because
there's some some beast out there you
know what i'm saying
so yeah and you know
manhandled by god too right like there's
certain times when i you know i'm
getting brash and i'm thinking too
highly of myself and i'm getting real
prideful and
egotistical and god is like oh you think
you're so tough
take this toward both my biceps that's
if i got man handle is i've been
manhandled by god the father he said
look
you're getting too big for your britches
tore both my biceps two of my achilles
tendon the very things that i make my
living from the very things that i pride
myself on right i pride myself on his
body
because i'm so strong and guy's like
look you're not you're not doing the
right thing
here's a little whooping and so i've
been handling that way many times too
and so the whole point of me asking that
you had said two things probably you
said uh religion
and what's the other thing if any of you
remember
in terms of like initiation process
movement yes
right you need austerity right austerity
or the challenge which is the right of
passage
and then religion religion offers
meaning it offers purpose it offers a
dignity right
i think dignity is so is so lacking
today
because the world teaches us that we
you're just a bag of bones
you're just a bag of bones and when you
die nothing happens
and you just you just rot in the ground
i think the cons
the idea that the soul is eternal gives
gives the human being
dignity right so we're robbed of our
dignity the minute you remove god and
and the afterlife and the soul
we lose our dignity as human beings then
we just you know what they like to tell
us
you're just an animal you're just an
animal just like the dogs that's the
craziest thing i've ever heard that
doesn't make any sense
i have much more dignity than my dog
yeah it's 100 what you said you said of
religion
and fasting like two key principles that
a man could do to start to kind of shift
his life around
and start you know going back into that
masculine frame
yeah and then the whole reason i brought
up the whole manhandling and stuff and
the way you worded it humiliation or
humility being humiliated
you know is like the third thing that
could be a good key
factor for someone because if someone's
got their ego on 100
there's no way that they're going to be
able to be the best man that they can be
that masculine figure that real
masculine
figure that's what the austerity is
about it's about humiliating
right humility is i like that word
humility humiliation
humor comes from the same root word and
so does humus which means dust
right the dirt the dirt is as humans in
it that's the nourishing part of the
dirt
and so it's very human even we're a
human right
human humility it's uh it's human to be
humble
[Music]
so what does humboldt mean to you
because i've heard a lot of things
it's like people don't have an exact
definition for it
knowing your place that's really what it
is knowing your
right place in the order of things
right knowing your right place in the
order of things
knowing that knowing where you
and i are not the authority knowing when
i'm to be subservient right there's a
time and there's a and there's a there's
an
order there's an order to life right not
everybody
is not everybody can be the leader not
right but they don't have us believe
that
everybody's a god right you could be
your own god not everybody's got not
everybody's a creator
not everybody's a leader and it's it's
humility to know
okay i'm under this or you know i'm
humbled to know that
enough to know that i am the authority
in this situation but i'm gonna carry
that with dignity i'm gonna carry that
respect you know what i'm saying
[Music]
all right so here's a little twist i
i've always been wondering this because
i've been a prospect of your journey for
past six seven years and i know that um
you weren't always religious or you know
maybe you had it
but it wasn't like it was kind of fluid
why don't you speak about that because i
know at one point you were
you were following the baha'i baha'i
faith
and i think it's interesting i want to
know like your perspective and like
what led you to where you are right now
well first by the grace of god i was
baptized catholic as a baby and that and
it didn't
it took me until i was you know almost
40 to realize that because
like most catholics my parents baptized
me and that was
pretty much it we went you know a few
times and i had i went to ccd actually i
went to
uh get my confirmation and things of
that nature
and i think right i don't know but i
think
in retrospect that that placed
a hunger for god in my life
there there was you know as most men
will say there's something
missing right there's something missing
i feel like there's something missing in
my life
and i i was grateful enough
to recognize that that hole could be
filled by the creator that that that
sense of uh dissatisfaction because they
say that only the only thing that could
truly satisfy us is god god is the only
true satisfier
um i started to notice it when i was
like uh in college
and i saw a bunch of guys praying on my
football team
right and at this point i didn't really
you know i wasn't really into anything
um i was listening to like i was
listening to alan watts on
on net and on napster right so i was
like into like uh
like buddhism and stuff like that like i
was just i wasn't a buddhist but i was
like
i really like listen to him so that was
as close as i could get to it
to abrahamic faith i'm sorry um
you know it was like eastern but then
when i saw these guys praying
just something again something just in
my heart was like
i should be on my knees that's that's
what i should be doing i was just drawn
to it immediately these guys on my
football team
they would pray before the games i was
like that's what i need to go do
and i went i started praying with them i
started going to the bible studies with
them
and and i felt like i was in the right
place um
but as with you know many things in my
life you know
i get hot i get hot about it i get
excited about it and then
you know things take over and it goes
away it kind of went away
then like i said i've been dating i've
been with my wife since i was in high
school
and um i was getting ready to go to
marines right when i graduated from
college i was ready
to go to the marines it was post-9 11
and
i was going to go anyway but because it
was post 9 11
everybody started wanting to go and they
kept pushing the dates back right
and for me because it was just like a
flood of people wanted to all of a
sudden want to become marines
and uh during that time because i was
gonna go away i was i wanted
i was getting married i was gonna get
married i wasn't married as my wife i
was gonna marry her back then
and um
i wasn't at the time i wasn't christian
uh and i had really i really hadn't
really thought about it that much but i
did see
i saw a pamphlet or i saw an ad or
something
for the baha'i faith and
i was curious about it because i'm a
mixed race man right living in america
and the baha'i faith was all about like
unity right and i was really drawn to
that i was like wow
you know it's like different people
different colors i was like i guess i
could vibe with that
and so i started reading the um the
writings of baha'u'llah
and i went through all his writings man
and i learned a lot about
islam because it comes out of islam too
so i even bought a quran
and i was reading the life of
prophet muhammad pbh and
i really i enjoyed it i loved it i
thought it was cool i
you know i was i was youthful i was a
kid i was like 22 years old
and then you know we got married my wife
got married we got married as behind it
was by
and then uh i moved to florida and all
that
i just kind of went out the window and
uh by such an
obscure faith there's not too many it's
not like a lot of baha'is
so when i came down to florida it kind
of just went away right i never thought
nothing of it
and i would just take my because i still
had a draw towards god
um i started taking my kids and my
family to like a protestant church to a
regular church
right i was like all right i mean it's
something that i think we should do
it's the right thing to do i think
religion is important
and so we did that for a little while
and then it just fell off again so if
you can see my journey is just like
back and forth back and forth and um
and then you know i became youtube
famous
and i was religious then i always been
religious but i'd never really been
i was i always
anchor for god i always there's always
something there for me
and so even when i was becoming youtube
famous i still
i still spoke of god i would still speak
about god i just wasn't
involved with any religion or anything
until i had a
i had a crisis of sorts where
you know i just i became 36 when i came
36 years old i was just like i'm not
sure what i'm doing
right and i guess it's that hankering
again that god is calling me again
i was like i don't know what i'm doing i
don't know what to do and
i don't know where to go i don't know
who i am anymore i just was going
through a little bit
a lot of confusion i started smoking
weed too right here i am at like 35
years old smoking weed i've never smoked
weed before in my life
here i am that's a great way to
disorient yourself so i started getting
even more disoriented because i'm like
i'm confused and i'm high and
uh i just you know it's not a miraculous
story or anything but
i remember one day maybe about three
years ago two and a half years ago
i was high and i was crying
and i was like lord i don't know what to
do take this away from me
just take this away from me i promise i
was just making all kinds of wow
promises and i'm just like praying to
god i don't even know what i'm doing
and he came over to me it came to me i
don't know if god spoke to me or what it
was but something came up in my heart to
elliot you've you've done a lot of wrong
things
i started feeling guilty i'm like wow
yeah damn
i really did screw up i did i did some
things that were not right and i started
thinking back about like
even when i was in high school just all
the things i all the sins that i've
committed
my whole life just started coming up and
it was even things that i didn't even
think was a sin like of course i was
fornicating with my wife before we
were married of course i married her but
i never thought anything of it but then
like
i came up i was like look at you man
you're a little kid having sex
and then just all these all the sins
just coming up
all the bad decisions i've made and
people i hurt
it started coming into my mind and i
just had this over some
overwhelming sense of guilt like i
deserve this like yeah my life is
hard right now and you know it's
subjectively you know everything looks
like it's great on the outside for my
life but i'm
tore up and the sense that came to me
was
ellie you need to go and
ask for forgiveness and repent of your
ways
you have to go and get this all off your
chest you gotta you need absolution
and you need to turn your turn your life
around right now
and so i didn't know what that meant i
didn't know what to do but i remembered
i was like who am i gonna confess to i
don't know anything about confession
uh i remember hey i'm catholic i can go
to the church and i can receive the
sacraments i could receive all the
sacraments i could receive the sacrament
of
reconciliation i never went to
confession before in my life
and i had to go on youtube and learn how
to do it like how do you how am i gonna
go confess to this priest like i know i
need to go do this
so on youtube start watching the videos
i i found the closest
parish i could find and i went and it
was
i went and i broke down and i was crying
in front of that priest
talk about being manhandled right that
was a manhandle moment for me
i was crying in front of you i was
sucking and
whining just like you know like i was
like i don't
it was it was humiliating
and um he didn't say he didn't really
speak english
very well he's a spanish guy he didn't
say anything
very profound he he he gave me the
absolution right and i walked out of
there
and i just wanted to keep coming back
some the thing with the catholic faith
is that
i get to go every day and receive the
body
of christ and it's a ritual or catholics
believe that the real presence of christ
is in is in the eucharist
and something just told me that that was
the right thing for me that i needed i
need to be with christ every single day
and you could you know you could go to
the protestant churches and
they open on sunday and that's it and
they don't even believe right there's a
lot of things they don't believe and i'm
not knocking anybody i'm not knocking
any religions
that's not my point i'm just telling
what i needed i needed the daily
presence
of the lord and so i just started going
to mass every day i was every day i was
the youngest one there because you know
all people that would go to stuff like
that i know muslims are a little
different because you guys are young and
you're devout there's not too many
it's coming more there's more catholics
that are coming around but but
these are all old people i'll be the
only young man there
and uh i'll go every single morning and
that really that changed
that just that ritual alone
revolutionized my mind
my whole way of being and uh so that's
where i am that's where i'm at today
do you feel at peace
no i'll never be at peace i don't think
that's
i don't think that's what i'm here for i
don't think anybody's
here for to be at peace we're here to
we're here to uh to
mortify this flesh so that we can purify
the soul
i'm here to sanctify myself and the
sanctification process
is not a peaceful process it's a battle
it's a war it's a spiritual
fight and so i'm fighting every day i
don't think i'll ever stop fighting
maybe
maybe maybe the grace of god will allow
peace to descend upon me
but i'm not i'm not waiting for that i
know that i have to fight
i have to fight daily this the demons
are always knocking on my door they're
always
whispering in my ear so there will be no
peace until they're all
obliterated and that's probably not
going to happen in my lifetime
i respect that but i mean when you go
and you worship
and you go to the mass and you go to
church and all that
you feel peace or you feel something
like that gives you
like ammo to your gun through this uh
it reminds me it gives me humility it
reminds me of
who i am one of the things that we do
when we go
and and and i love the way you guys pray
too right because you get down in your
face
you get down on your face what that what
happened when you get down on your face
it reminds you of who you are one of the
things that we do in catholic mass
is you you beat your chest and you say
you commit you
by my fault my fault my own grievous
fault so it's like
you're in a way you're beating yourself
up to remind yourself that
i'm a sinner i'm screwing up i'm not
perfect
i'm trying my best and hopefully god
will forgive me but every day
you beat your chest to remind yourself
hey look
i ain't i'm not perfect i'm making
mistakes
i can do better i can do better so when
i go
i have a sense of reverence this is what
i thought i really
fed me was a sense of reverence walking
into a holy place
right there's not many holy places in
our world anymore
you guys go to mosque maz is a is a holy
place
but the secular world most of it there's
nothing holy about it that everything is
profane
and so walking into a holy place that in
itself gave me a sense of
reverence again humility i feel
low right because this place is about on
high
and i want to feel low i don't want to
feel high the world makes me feel high
all the time
oh elliot you're you're a god i need to
go to a place that remind me
i'm not a god right then i get down on
my knees
i get down on my knees and to receive
the eucharist
you go down on your knees and you open
your mouth like a dog
that's humility that's humiliating
so i go there to not for peace
right and i'm not saying i'm right
because people other people tell you
different things
let me tell you what happened to me i go
there hang in my head
i go there down on my knees i go there
begging and pleading
lord forgive me and that's my attitude
about it
otherwise i've been very i've had
prideful spirituality before
where i and i remember i like and i and
it's one of the things i had to
uh ask for forgiveness for praying to
god what kind of brashness
god like you know how a lot of these
like new agers like they
and even some of the you know abrahamic
religions where they you know they're
talking to god like it's their best
friend like
you know and and all charismatic and
stuff like no i
that don't work for me i gotta bow my
head
in humility and speak to god and that
from that place this
that's what it does for me and that's
what i need
would you say that that allows you to
have uh
the god consciousness where you you're
just aware of god
because you said you you've had some
sort of a
level of religious level of uh
spirituality in your life
throughout your entire life but it's
like being
where you are now doing what you're
doing now allows you to keep that alive
versus
before it was like i might come here but
then it might be like a few months
before
you know you uh get off your ego trip
and then
get into this i and this is a way i was
looking for religions
in the past and i think a lot of people
this is where they get caught up in new
age and stuff
a lot of people we looking for what
religion could do
for us like you know god is like a genie
right and i'm gonna and if i if i do the
right thing say the right things and i
rub this rub it the right way god can
give you what i want
people are looking for all kinds of
bliss and nirvana
and enlightenment they're looking for
all this pleasurable experiences that's
why they're going out into the amazon
and drinking that ayahuasca and getting
high and thinking that it's god
they're just looking for stuff they're
looking for feelings that's really what
it is
it's the real it's the religion of
emotionalism
and so there was a time when i was when
i was looking for that right i wanted to
get a high from god because everything
else gives you a high in this world
right
and so like i said the difference is
that i don't look for that high anymore
and if you stop looking for the high you
won't be disappointed right like if
you're constantly looking for a high
and you're not getting that high anymore
you get disappointed you keep looking
around we're gonna get that next high
that's why i say
you know wheat is a gateway drug because
it's like this is not giving me the high
no more
i gotta go get that next one and i would
get a high but
i don't get i don't seek highs anymore
and that's the biggest difference that's
why i won't be bouncing around so much
because i'm low i'm low now and so if it
don't feel good
that's the right way if it's painful
that's the right way if it's the narrow
path that's the right way and so the
different the difference is
that if if it if it's
hard right now that i'm where i am right
now if it's hard
that means i'm on the right path if it's
easy if it's ecstasy
that's not the right path you're moving
in the direction of resistance of
resistance
yeah i'm i guess you i don't
i don't really know what you mean by
that moving like resistance like it's
not easy
it's not ecstasy it's not pleasure and
maybe that's a trip too
you know maybe that's the ego trip for
me too but i know that it keeps me
reverent
it and it keeps me humble and that's
that's the right thing for me i can't i
can't be a part of something that's
all too celebratory it needs to be
somber it needs to be
it needs to be low
i feel that it's powerful it's probably
one
honestly though like i speak for myself
here i don't speak fired i don't speak
for romney i don't speak for all the
muslims
um and what i'm about to say a lot of
people might disagree with me but
look i never cared if someone looked
down on me or disagreed on me but
from what i'm seeing like you were
pulled in that direction
right that's what you said
pulled and you felt pulled was like
you're like
i gotta go to god i gotta do something
it i don't know if i was pulled but it
came down upon me
it was rather than pull it was like boom
right it's like it just it collapsed
down upon me
right pull is one thing but boom i was
like oh
got you got you but it was something
something happened where it's like
it was a shift in your life yeah
like something had to change right and
we can't say like oh that's just some
random thing
because you can't keep writing things
off as coincidence because
a lot of times things happen in such a
way where it's like dude there's no way
that this can be a coincidence
right so it's like
like i said i'm gonna say this for
myself and i don't even say this because
you're
your host is not me being a fanboy or
anything this is me just being
real with you and i think that if uh
god is guiding you in that direction and
that's
allowing you to keep moving forward you
know
come close to god and work through
this this uh matrix that we're living in
then by all means
yeah i don't overthink it and i don't
think i don't overtake it for myself and
i don't
overthink it for other people i'm simple
in my faith
that's another big difference for me
right now i'm not
intellectual about it i don't
intellectualize it
i don't it just sound might sound crazy
it's a lot of people tell me i'm crazy
when i say this but
i don't question it too much i'm not
trying to figure it out because that's
the ego trip for me
i'm a thinker and i'm an
intellectualizer and so i just keep it
simple just keep it real
simple and so uh yeah yeah
that's that's that's what work that's
what works for me man
again i say this for myself because it's
like
i understand like god's gonna guide
people
however he's gonna guide them like um
a lot of people will say no no what i'm
believing
is the correct way and you know if you
ask me i would say no islam is the way
but i also understand that god guides
people in different
ways and like if i were to neglect that
if i were to only say no
um this is the only way and listen to
everyone else well then i would neglect
the fact that i
was guided to islam was like that in and
of itself was
guidance where someone else might have
guidance in a different direction but
again by all means if it's allowing you
to worship god it's allowing you to come
closer to god it's allowing you to
cut through this matrix and humble
yourself then
by all means yeah yep yeah i feel the
same way i feel the same way about you
same thing man all right it's it's all
right
it's all good right it's all god
that's facts so
a big question that i have and um
this is backtracking again
i'm gonna actually pause right there i'm
gonna let one of y'all join me because i
completely got a blank slate
i completely forgot what i was gonna ask
no worries man
you do it like three times an episode
you're romney real quick
now your mic's cutting out bro move it
romney i was gonna say
mike a little closer to you oh okay can
you guys hear me
100 bro okay thank you um i was just
kind of in awe the entire time
um it was it was really inspiring
subhanallah
um a lot of a lot of different you know
verses and stories came to my mind
like for example allah says the servants
of the most merciful
are those who walk the earth with
humility and then he actually goes on to
give an example
those who when they're greeted by
ignorant people they respond with salam
peace you know words of peace and and
the prophet peace be upon him
uh to kind of back that up he says that
um
basically teaches us not to argue right
don't uh don't get in arguments and all
that and that he'll guarantee like a
house in heaven for those
who give up arguing even if they're
right because there's so many things
that you know
there's no good that comes out of at the
end of the day right yeah so
the whole thing about humility really
hit home for me and all i could think
about is like when we go to the mosques
and we're praying in what we call
jeremiah which is like
we're all praying together you're just
one
body in a whole row of people right
and you're just you know praying with
your head facing downward
and thinking about god reciting god's
words and it's just the most humbling
uh experience i've ever had in my life
thankfully
it was really you know beautiful hearing
that you know come from yourself it was
really you know reassuring
hearing the talk of humility again i
feel like i needed it to be honest
good hey fellas i have an appointment at
uh 3
30. i i thought we'd be done by now
could i pick could i uh part ways with
you guys
or you can do what you got to do yeah
they're blowing
me up right now of course hey it was
great yeah i'm happy i was able to
connect with you guys you guys are doing
some good stuff man keep up the great
work
we appreciate it so much thank you so
much and you as well i know you do it
you said you do it for the money but uh
may god grant you uh more we making men
strong we're making men strong again
that's really what's happening anyway
so god's billy appreciate man we
appreciate you for making the time man
wish you the best okay great fellas talk
soon
for sure take care see ya
all right before we end it with that
being said that was elia tuls
my god bless him do i just remember what
i was gonna ask him man
come on i was gonna ask him i was gonna
ask him
what does he think about purpose now for
a man
after or before he was in religion and
after he came to religion
i mean a great question inshallah i mean
here's the thing bro maybe
maybe part two guys hit us up if you uh
if you like this episode like comment
subscribe
and any parting words from uh ango
you've been kind of silent most of the
episode bro
so uh you want to say something
i've been the most talkative one bro
yeah you have bro you damn right you
have
um but hopefully you got some of your
questions
uh and insight answered now
for rami i want you to end this off but
give me give me like a closing uh line
or two bro
just because he's the thing for anyone
watching this even though elliot left a
call
i just want to let him know that me and
anger have been extensively following
him
not to some you know shirky idolatry
type sense but
we look up to the guy we give praise
where it's due and
he has really made a difference and
impact in my life
and i think my brother angel can say the
same
but for you this was one of your first
encounters
with your house getting to know him so
what are your thoughts ma'am
um really really humble guy i'm glad i
didn't have
the box that you guys are mentioning
where i put him in this box and i
expected him to be this way i just kind
of like
i've heard him talk a few times i don't
really know too much uh
so it's just kind of like a normal
interaction like no you run into someone
kind of get to know them
um but he is very very i think i
just mature and humble i think it's a
beautiful thing
um i would also add like focus like he
seems like he knows what he wants to do
what his mission is like he said at the
end making men
men again making men strong um i think
it's a beautiful thing i think
uh he's a very uh properly guided guy
honestly and someone to look up to
alhamdulillah
may allah may god guide him and continue
to guide him and guide all of us
all right it was dope
i'm not gonna lie it was dope because i
did
i feel like a part of me was expecting
him to
express himself in a certain way and
just to
just to talk with him in a very humble
sense
and very candid but very humble it uh
it was it was nice it was refreshing man
i agree with you this is
day three or four of ramadan
when you guys are gonna be watching this
so uh
he's right man at the end of the day
ramadan is a death to the dunya just to
your material shackles and things that
possess you and hold you
um and kind of make you submit to them
in a way
whether you realize it or not whether
you like that or not right at the end of
the day like
some people don't see the wisdom in in
ramadan and fasting and
religiosity as a whole how many people
are watching this that don't even know
anything about islam
or religiosity or god or even theism
right and me you may be rami as well
we've definitely gone through our own
roller coaster of our outlook on these
things right we weren't born
with 100 you know iman or you know taqwa
you know consciousness belief in allah
and god uh
it was something that you know it's not
an overnight thing
right but that's the thing essentially
you get out of the way you stop trying
to be god
you know religion islam it's not about
you trying to see if you know god or the
truth
um you know aligns with your values you
know people don't look at it like that
people see
oh dude does does the truth align with
me it's not do i align with the truth
right it's does the truth align with me
you know
so they kind of go into it with this
expectation that it's it's not more so
you know
do i agree with you guys it's more so do
you guys agree with me
if not i could just get the hell out of
here and you know we could just plot
ways and
uh not put our differences aside but
he's right in the in the same way
you know however we can all find truth
and meaning
uh into god but with that being said man
um ramadan
is a perfect time for us to understand
that and put that in the forefront
and put our desires and and whims and
and these
little things that don't matter in the
back burner right no
it doesn't have to be forever but if you
guys are not even muslim
right if you guys are not religious or
practicing
and you want to you want to give it a
shot just give it a shot bro 30 days
you know you guys missed a few days if
you haven't already started but
it's just fasting it's essentially you
know obviously this is not medical
advice so if you
you got some underlying health condition
predisposition maybe maybe consult your
physician
uh but with that being said if you want
to just give it a shot you know
you're not muslim you kind of want to
see what it's about who knows maybe this
will bring you
uh you know more peace at the very least
and
a new way of thinking and paradigm shift
the best or at the most
so give it a shot you know no food or
drinking no sexual intercourse
no you know haram right from sun up till
sundown
shouldn't be too hard right because uh
you know
but but then again people today you tell
them uh be away from your phone for five
minutes they can't even do that people
don't realize how addictive they are
right
just like brother eliot said so give it
a shot let's see let's see what happens
let us know
um ramadan 2021
if you made it this far and i'll let
brother rami end it off
dude before you even before you even end
it off man
yo i'ma have so many muslims at my neck
bro
for what i said oh that god guides
people
yeah yeah yeah i'ma have a lot of people
sending me some hate messages but it is
what it is
boys i mean in my opinion as long as
allah guides them eventually to islam
then you could say that but if you say
like allah guides them
to some secular worldview
it doesn't really make sense that's
that's not what i say what i see
is more so like allah
guides people to him
yeah and islam
may be the way that this person is
guided to him
and for another person it might be
something else
not it's always going to be having
something to do with spirituality and
with
god going back to god but it's like at
the end of the day
again if you ask me i'll say oh well
islam is the way because it's
it's it's what i practice it's what i've
been guided to and it's what allows me
to come back to god so it's like but for
another person
it might not be that it might be
something else and like who is it
who are we to judge them
like at the end of the day we're not the
ones judging them and
saying they're gonna go to jannah
they're gonna go to jahannam
like no no no it's allah so it's like
that's that's all i pretty much was
saying
but uh again some muslims might be at my
neck
just saying something like that no but i
do believe bravo
100 and everyone has their way of
finding the truth everyone has a message
to come to them
right but as long as you are receptive
you will get there you know i love ellie
helsing elliot if you are watching this
episode after you left this little post
recording
session right here with the t3m uh
i mean no offense when i say this but
the only thing that i would personally
not
agree with myself and it's okay to agree
to disagree
is uh the whole thing about just being a
little like
okay i'm not gonna question things too
much that's just me
because for me i can't not question
things because then i won't find peace
then i'm kind of doing it for the wrong
reasons
and you know if it works for you it
works for you and
this doesn't go to everyone but for me
if something doesn't sit right with me i
got a question
and that's why we believe that if you
are in any position you are
um you're essentially being guided to
islam like rami says but you need to
stay
in a position where you are in a in a
receptive state to be guided you cannot
be
uh kind of like okay i know everything
because um just like ali too if eliot
was in that
in that state where he identified with
his ego he wouldn't have started you
know
questioning things finding you know
connecting with his fitrah
which is your innate belief in god uh
coming to you know the baha'i faith and
then coming to christianity
or catholicism and it wouldn't have
worked out same with us i wouldn't have
come to islam
um fully understanding it and practicing
it to this day if i didn't really
question things and understand
its validity as truth right so i i
advise and still promote all of you guys
watching these guys and girls to
question
everything as allah tells us himself in
the quran
to question everything don't just
believe the religion of your forefathers
because it's the religion of your
forefathers right
it's up to you and it's your life when
it's all said and done
you can't use these excuses like oh i
just did this because of this person
with that person
i mean i think like eventually gets to a
point where it's like over skepticism
and all of that but that's true
my messages don't look at it as
you know does the truth align with my
values and my truth and my reality no
look at it as okay do i believe
in the truth in reality what he said
what elliott said in the beginning about
objective objectivity not subjectivity
yeah i agree and it's like what rami
said way back
where it's like if you go to one extreme
you'll probably end up
leaving that and then going to the other
extreme where it's like
and then also one extreme will breed the
other extreme
so it's like you have to find that
middle path
and it's like i get what you're saying
too
you're saying um instead of
not questioning you should question but
you shouldn't over
question where you you start getting
super skeptical and then you don't
believe anything
then you're like an atheist you know
what i mean
but then if you believe everything then
you're too gullible and then
you're like uh these are new age people
yeah these these spiritual nuts want to
decalcify their pineal gland and
awaken the third eye and all that geez
i'm just playing i'm just playing but uh
with that being said
you guys made it this far and you are
ready for your serving your daily dose
of cognitive dissonance and paradigm
shifts
go to our channel bro don't even
subscribe alright we're not out here for
clout
just go to episode one start your
journey there don't even like the video
help dislike the video
go to episode 1 start your journey there
and
may allah may god truly guide you
through this wonderful journey of
introducing allah god himself
religion into your life into your
secular life if this is you
if you're already out here ten toes down
alhamdulillah subhanallah but
this is for the people that don't really
understand religion don't really believe
in it
um it's why we started this channel
there is a reason rationale behind the
sequence of events
of the episodes it's not episode one
wasn't episode one just because
you feel me angel's not wearing his uh
red camo shirt just because
there's a reason behind everything right
rami didn't hold the mic far away
and then bring it closer just because
everything happens for a reason so
that being said bro if anger is you know
has nothing else to add on and
off how about we uh don't
you know encourage them to dislike the
video let's
encourage them to like the video share
the video
with their grandma their cousins out my
bad their buzzins boys
yes and the brewers and the brewers uh
dude what was the hashtag that you said
for this video i said ramadan
2021 yeah if you made it this far
hashtag ramadan 2021 and put hashtag
dailydoseofd and i'm not talking about
that deep
you sick people i'm talking about what
are you talking about dissonance
i thought it was the daily dose of dean
oh
okay that works of d
d and whoever made it this far will
understand what we're talking about if
anyone leaves
some immature comment saying oh we are
immature
we are not pious and we are like little
kids and narcissistic
hate well um you ain't make it this far
so rami go ahead and end it no before
that
guys please make some dua for angel and
every other reverb that we'll be doing
ramadan for the first time
this year and may allah make it very
easy
and show them that it's so much more
beneficial
than our ego and minds constructed to be
harmful
right and all these excuses oh will i
die will i do this will i dehydrate will
i lose my gains
it's not really about that but may allah
allow them to just vibe with the truth
and truly get
a lot of value from this ramadan i mean
if uh if anyone is a reaver
and they're also doing ramadan feel free
to message me
um i won't respond but it makes you feel
better
feel free to message me if you want
someone that responds go ahead and hit
up romney
or fire those two are on it a hundo
but with that being said we got nothing
but love for you
alaikum warahmatullahi
um this dude over here is better looking
than me
and a girl would probably want to be
with him more than me and
it was just dumb things going on in my
head but it's like
hey that's what was going on in my head
at the time
and for me to sit down and just like
observe it without any judgment
allowed me to see like oh okay that's
going on in the background
let me let me work on that let me be
more aware of that
let me put in some more effort to be
able to be more mindful and more present
and get past that
you feel me so like to me that's my
favorite form of meditation but
either meditation is fine just the fact
that if you can meditate at least 15 to
30 minutes a day
you will see the benefits
[Music]
um
[Music]